you see I know what you're thinking
you're thinking dude Jeremy you said Red
Dead Redemption review you promised that
I heard you say it and I did but my
rpgfan friends out there will agree and
they'll know what I'm talking about when
I say I started playing an RPG and I
went through the entire RPG and I beat
it because it was awesome and now I got
to talk about this RPG so let's talk
about it because it's an RPG worth
talking about
Final Fantasy 6 or Final Fantasy 3 as it
was called on the Super NES in America
and the Wii Virtual Console still I
believe for the sake of this review I'm
going to call it Final Fantasy 6 because
that's what it is all right so Final
Fantasy 6 is an RPG from what I call the
Golden Age of Squaresoft they they
really put their time in their RPGs back
then you can tell just the entire crew
had the mindset they're like this is our
Deerhunter our eiffel tower and it shows
in games like this I saw at least in my
circle of friends and people I know and
talk to and I'm pretty sure people
online there are a couple of debates
going on in the RPG communities which is
what's better Final Fantasy 6 or Final
Fantasy 7 or what's better Final Fantasy
6 or Chrono Trigger either way Final
Fantasy 6 is in the middle of all this
so that's the one we're going to talk
about so Final Fantasy 6 is a sprite
based RPG from the Super Nintendo era
and none of these 3d graphics no sprites
you know old-school and as much as it
sounds like that compromises the
experience it does not compromise the
experience at all a thousand years ago
magic was really abundant it was
everywhere and it led to the War of the
Magi which completely leveled the entire
planet the world was a wasteland and
then magic just simply vanished then
steam and : Industrial built the
world back up that's what technology is
running on now because Magic's gone or
so everyone thinks but there is a bit of
it left and a couple of maniacs are
gonna try to get that magic and harness
it but they run the risk of wiping out
the world again so the good guys have to
stop them just how the game starts out
the game is just completely cinematic
and you're like ok I'm in for something
a little more than just some sprite
based RPG I'm gonna make it brief I'm
not gonna go into detail about this but
it starts out on this hill there's this
one chick she's a magic chick and she's
being controlled by the Empire with this
crown to have magitek armor and they're
looking at this town they're like yeah
we got to go get this Esper which are
you know magic things and so they're
like let's go wipe out this town and get
this Esper and this chick is a good
person but she's being controlled so
they all locked down and one of the
greatest themes ever made in videogame
history plays as the cameras behind them
and they're walking towards this town it
was super nintendo graphics back but it
was like advanced Super Nintendo
graphics this town just coming closer
while this theme is playing in the
beginning credits start you're like
that's what movies do but it happened in
1994 on a Super Nintendo game and then
from there you meet a plethora of some
of the most relatable characters in RPG
history and you go about your business
you know trying to save the world what
hi welcome to my channel where we talk
about what I think is cool now in an RPG
game plays really important you're gonna
be fighting leveling and grinding
through the battles so let's at least
make that enjoyable and balanced Final
Fantasy 6 does it really well you can
teach every character all the magic what
the characters do have specific
abilities specific to them giving them
their own flavor and I love that you'd
be surprised at how many RPGs just go
alright yeah I teach everyone everything
and just make them the same person
really Final Fantasy 6 was like now you
can teach everyone the spells but they
have their own abilities also but who
are we kidding you teach everyone Ultima
you break the game and you win that's
just what will happen another element in
RPGs that's important are the characters
like I said these characters and Final
Fantasy 6 some of the most relatable
ever made I mean their little sprites
you shouldn't relate to them I mean you
relate to Mass Effect 2 characters yeah
but sprites really yeah really because
every character has relevance you have
these side quests that you can do for
the characters and it just you learn a
little more about them there's a
character named shadow he's a ninja he
really hops into your party when he
feels like he's one of those mercenary
types he'll fight with you until he
feels like he doesn't have to anymore
then he just leaves he might see him
again you might not at a point in the
game he does permanently join your party
if you have patience and wait for him
but you would think that'd be the
character with the lightest story all
right mercenary character who's gonna
care the answer yeah you because the
story they give him is really good don't
get me wrong the crew in seven cloud
teef of Erath I love them all but the
characters and Final Fantasy 6 I got
more attached to and I was thinking
about I was like why is that because
Final Fantasy 6 has again what a lot of
games these days don't have which makes
me sound really old it is game related
days I don't mean to be like that but
I'm just saying the characters and Final
Fantasy 6 had their own theme not only
is the theme to Final Fantasy 6 one of
the best themes ever made but the
character themes are fantastic I mean
let's be honest about this we can't talk
about Final Fantasy 6 without talking
about its soundtrack in its soundtracks
composer Nobuo Uematsu the guy is a
genius complete musical genius for
comparison's sake imagine paint to a
painter is like an orchestra for a
composer in which case using 16-bit
Super Nintendo MIDI technology to create
music would be like a painter painting
with Crayola Crayons what did Naboo
about to do with that technology he
created the Sistine Chapel with Crayola
Crayons metaphorically speaking
I consider the Final Fantasy 6
soundtrack to be his masterpiece in more
ways than
one I could just listen to it all day
long you're listening to it you're like
oh yeah there's shadow again there's
cyan there's Tara and you're just right
back there emotionally with the
characters that you've bonded with which
are sprites from a Super Nintendo game I
guess that's the most impressive thing
about Final Fantasy 6 when characters
are 3d rendered you expect that they're
going to feel more human that's not
always the case these sprites feel more
human than most things I've seen in
games today there's this one scene with
an opera it's one of the classic moments
in this game where this one chick she
was raised to be a warrior in this
Empire and now she's working with you
but she's ultimately like I've been bred
for war I know nothing else and this one
dude one of your other guys his name is
Locke he has kind of a crush on her and
they have their own little thing going
on so this has romantic elements in it
too and she does this opera and it's one
of these humanizing moments where she's
like I am more than just a dog of war
like if Solid Snake learned that he
could live for more than war that's this
moment in this game not knocking Solid
Snake but I'm just saying that it was
just it was a really good humanizing
moment in an RPG and it happened in
16-bit glory and also was important in
any RPG as well as any game is a great
villain Final Fantasy 6 has a great
villain that's another battle going on
within the RPG community which villain
is better Final Fantasy 6 is Kefka Final
Fantasy 7 Sephiroth both are badasses
but you really they're hard to compare
Sephiroth was like Darth Vader he's
really menacing and stoic and you know
when he's in the room his business
and if Sephiroth is like Darth Vader I
would say kefka is like the Joker that
kefka is like the joker if the Joker
actually had the force like Darth Vader
had magic and became a demigod and this
is spoiler ish here but it's worth
touching on he actually is the villain
that wins that's another reason I love
this game so much villains never win
Sephiroth and Final Fantasy 7 tried to
bring a meteor down on the earth but
they fought and they won so many movies
so many games out there like oh we need
to stop the world from ending kefka's
like yeah two-thirds of the way through
Final Fantasy 6 I win the world gets
burned to the ground your crew is
scattered it picks up a year later and
you have to gather everybody together to
beat kefka but the world still burned
it's over all you can do is take him out
and hope that you rebuild i love that
having the balls to tell a story where
the villain actually does win and you
show that the world doesn't actually
stop at that point
oh yeah it's completely destroyed but
it's not over there are still people
alive if you have that thought in your
head like you know they don't make a
game like that I wish they would they
did its Final Fantasy 6 or 3 for the
Super Nintendo play square has done a
crusade or two about re releasing their
old Final Fantasy games with souped-up
3d graphics at first I was like oh
that'd be cool to see what six
especially on like ps3 graphics all in
cinematic glory that still would be cool
but ultimately I don't know if I want
them to really dick with it that much
it's great as it is just HD up the
sprites like they did with Final Fantasy
4 on the PSP re-release it that way I
would buy that and play the out of
it if you do take my advice and go out
to get this game to play it get the Game
Boy Advance version or the Wii Virtual
Console version those are really close
to the Super Nintendo versions not
really suggesting the PlayStation
Network version that you can download
for like 5 or 10 bucks because it's the
ps1 version that they released on the
PlayStation 1 but it I didn't like the
emulator some of the sounds were
different set of slashes they were thuds
the battles infuriated me in the Super
Nintendo version and the Game Boy
Advance version get into a battle it's
like blah you know it hits you in the
face you know okay we're ready for about
PlayStation versions of fate it's all
fade load time boring so yeah Game Boy
Advance Wii Virtual Console version or
if you prefer play it legit the funny
thing about the Final Fantasy games is
they're so different throughout time
that people are going to say their
favorite Final Fantasy is this this that
that because of nostalgia that's really
what it's there for
nostalgic Lee bring you back to that
time that you dumped a hundred hours
into a game when you didn't have to but
you did because you loved it and in that
a lot of people's first RPG was Final
Fantasy 7 mine was - that was the first
Final Fantasy that I played Final
Fantasy 7 that's my nostalgic Final
Fantasy I didn't play Final Fantasy 6
until it came out for the Game Boy
Advance I brother played the out of
it in the 90s so I was like oh yeah that
that game that you were ball hogging the
TV with yeah I don't want to play that
but I finally did and Final Fantasy 7
being my nostalgic game I'm saying to me
Final Fantasy 6 is actually better not
knocking 7 7 is fantastic it's a great
game I'd love to review that after Red
Dead Redemption I did make that promise
there's something about 6 it's one of
the greatest RPGs ever made to me the
one that rivals it to me is Chrono
Trigger so I prefer Chrono Trigger or
Final Fantasy 6 the answer is yes test I
can do for you I would love to
you Final Fantasy 6 be like an HBO
series you know three seasons long
live-action make it like Game of Thrones
I would die happy in fact if there's a
producer out there who wants to start a
Kickstarter I will contribute to that so
like I said one of the greatest RPGs
ever for me most relatable characters
killer soundtrack badass villain great
plot great story great battle system I
can't find any flaws in this game the
only flaw is that in the older versions
like Super Nintendo version there's no
run button you walk until you get sprint
shoes but until then walk Final Fantasy
6 is without a doubt of a caliber all
its own and it is awesome tacular right
in the world of subjective opinions for
Final Fantasy games I have not counted
you out every opinion counts every
opinion matters what is your favorite
final fantasy game out there comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you